cuando el ejército ruso entró a Bob
chance su ciudad dimitro chirinov
acababa de salir de prisión
procesado por secuestro extorsión y
lesiones agravadas acababa de salir en
Libertad bajo fianza los rusos lo
nombraron alcalde
ahora que Bob chansk vuelve a ser de
Ucrania se ha añadido La traición a la
lista de cargos en su contra un
de los 40 casos de colaboración con el
ocupante examinados por este tribunal
este es uno de los menos problemáticos
los casos en los que los rusos se
emplean a delincuentes son bastante
comunes
Porque estos delincuentes Ya tienen sus
redes de apoyo listas para violar la ley
torturar matar y saquear
la mayoría de los funcionarios empleados
por los rusos para administrar las
ciudades ocupadas huyeron a Rusia antes
de que llegara el ejército ucraniano
caído en desgracia dimitro chirinov fue
arrestado cuando intentaba huir a través
de Ucrania
en Bob chans prefieren no mencionarlo no
lo conozco
es un Bandido
[Risas]
no me interesa lo que hacen estos
mafiosos vivo tranquilo cuanto menos sé
mejor estoy no quiero que me lleven en
medio de la noche
aquí los pocos habitantes que quedan
sobreviven gracias a la ayuda
humanitaria antes de la guerra este
pueblo a seis kilómetros de la frontera
vivía del comercio con Rusia sus
habitantes Siempre han sido prorusos en
su mayoría
miles de residentes de siguieron a las
tropas rusas a Rusia se acaban de ir de
la noche a la mañana Tatiana bondareva
es una profesora originaria de Bob
chansk según ella los rusos se
arrepintieron rápidamente de haber
contratado a chirineo rápidamente lo
sacaron de su cargo porque era incapaz
de liderar la región
lo que aprueba que de alguna manera
estaban tratando de mantener el orden
inevitablemente se arrojaron así el
apoyo a la población que ya sin él
tendría que apoyar
después de una reunión con sus
compañeros en la que tetiana les hizo
saber que no cooperaría los soldados
rusos llegaron a su casa cuando mis
propios Compañeros me envían terroristas
armados que me sacan con un arma
apuntándome frente a mis hijos me da
tristeza
de Tiana logró huir pero la mayoría de
sus compañeros profesores se quedaron y
colaboraron
programa comenzaron a enseñar a los
niños de acuerdo con los planes de
estudios escolares rusos recibieron
salarios rusos Creo que deberían ser
castigados
si dicen que no tuvieron elección tienen
derecho a decirlo pero creo que la
mayoría de mis colegas tenían otra
opción
Cuando miro las fotos de mis alumnos
muertos en el frente todas mis dudas
desaparecen
murieron para defendernos a nosotros y a
mis compañeros que al mismo tiempo
trabaja n para los que mataron a
nuestros estudiantes
pero la casa de colaboradores también su
cita críticas
nuestros centros de prisión preventiva
están repletos de profesores secretarios
de alcaldías funcionarios
en el auto o en la calle y trato de no
Llamar demasiado la atención
Mira hay demasiada gente allí vamos al
otro lado no hay nadie en su coche es
bitlana recoge testimonios de los
compañeros de una profesora a la que
defiende
aquí que ha leído correctamente el texto
Eso es todo muchas gracias Espero que
lleguemos allí sin un juicio
pero si va juicio entonces podría ser
citada como testigo
desde la liberación el ambiente extenso
los vecinos se acusan mutuamente de
haber colaborado
solo porque estuvimos ahí tratando de
sobrevivir en toda esta situación
fue duro muy duro durante cinco meses de
ocupación más de 2.000 civiles murieron
en mitsune son recuerdos dolorosos
entre los clientes de spitlanna están
los padres de un policía que colaboró
cómo pueden decir que lo hizo a
propósito cuando los rusos lo golpearon
no mató a nadie
no robó nada
sobre todo perseguía a saqueadores
y está siendo castigado por eso y
nuestra policía Dónde estaba vinieron
después
se lo llevaron y durante 10 días no
supimos Dónde estaba
su hijo vitalikachenko fue secuestrado
el 12 de septiembre pero oficialmente su
arresto Data del 23 su madre no lo
volvió a ver hasta siete meses después
en la corte
por haber servido Durante un mes en la
policía de ocupación le esperan hasta 15
años de prisión lo que realmente no
esperaba no me estaba escondiendo estaba
caminando por la calle los oficiales
revisaron mis documentos y tuve que
seguirlos bitlana intenta que vitallica
chenco sea liberado bajo fianza la
detención continua de mi cliente viola
sus derechos constitucionales pero como
siempre en los casos de colaboración su
solicitud fue rechazada sin reformas y
sin personal el sistema judicial
ucraniano enfrenta hoy una situación sin
precedentes